c'était l'événement hier pour tous les
fans des téléphones de la marque à la
pomme l'iphone merde
le 12 a été présenté lors de la
traditionnelle keynote de la marque à la
pomme donc ce n'est pas un téléphone qui
a été présenté mais quelques différends
et à l'iphone mini le 12 mai l iphone ou
alors à partir de 809 euros après il ya
le 12 à 909 euros il ya de 12 pro à 1159
euros et le 12 promax à 1259 euros s'ils
ne nous prennent pas pour des cons on
les aime bien mais là et mais qu'ils en
ont fait quatre ça veut dire faire est
un téléphone à 1326 arrivée dans la
salle un jeune chauffard n'a pas de
téléphone de la personne chez moi
j'habite six personnes et je suis
content regardez ils en ont parlé sur
bfm aujourd'hui à la page parce qu'apple
a dévoilé hier soir l'iphone 12
alors forcément la grande nouveauté
c'est la 5g
ça sert à rien en tout cas de changer de
smartphone uniquement pour prendre un
smartphone 5g la 5g en france ce sera
dans deux trois ans dans les grandes
villes
et là cette année ya une petite
nouveauté c'est l'iphone 12 min on a
toutes les fonctions haut de gamme de
l'iphone 12
donc c'est un petit iphone mais très
performant tous les iphone ont un écran
oled
l'écran oled c'est important parce que
ça permet d'avoir un taux de contraste
infini et franchement ça change quand
même les choses donc maintenant c'est de
life de l'écran oled pour tous entre
guillemets
[Applaudissements]
l'iphone regarder en 2007 j'ai regardé
regardez regardez regardez regardez
maintenant regarder les prix commencent
à augmenter sa écouter away 1609
ouais c'est incroyable bond iphone qui
est vendu 1300 euros et le fabrique pour
450 euros
non mais donc ils sont une marge énorme
c'est un peu indécent trouve aujourd'hui
c'est fou qui va là je t'ai dit la
vérité
non ça fait des années que de change à
chaque fois je suis pas le seul c'est un
vrai hein c'est bon marketing apple
c'est la réussite c'est que des gens qui
ont la version d'avant sont beaux ils
changent vous de façon même si vous
prenez le groupe vous aurez l'impression
que c'est juste vous allez maintenant
apple est très mal parce qu'on peut
enfin vous pas dire apple mais on peut
venir de la pomme
enfin il vous reprennent assez bien
l'ancien sexuelle acquis et le 12 avril
le reprennent à moitié prix quand même
un peu baissé et soraya curieux tiens
qu'est ce qu'on fait je vais tester les
jeux à venir je vais je suis non apple
pourquoi pas au d'argent et on va faire
un beau merci merci et en plus ils ont
même pas 1000 adaptateur avec ses
parents alors excusez moi tout ça en
prétextant que ça fait baisser
l'empreinte carbone de la fabrication
est fait alors qu'en fait c'est pour
faire des économies
ils ont fait + 25 % la pomme au deuxième
trimestre de cette année dans un marché
qui s'effondrait et nous enlève
l'adaptateur c'est vraiment prendre les
gens pour des cons la ville est ce que
vous allez acheter l'iphone d'où les
connais pas je m'en fous
7 au moins c'est la modernité ils sont
également et puis j'ai fait tout ce que
je veux dire c'est que si pratique que
ses prix oui qui savent qu'à des côtes
dîtes ça pour benjamin castaldi sahraoui
a pas que lui celle ci n'a eu que lui
l'aurait pas sorti mais s'il ya des
comme pilate et atb mais genre les
emmerdes
il faut quand même reconnaître que peu
de gens l'achètent
à ce prix là parce qu'en fait en général
c'est englobé dans des forfaits qui font
tant globez quand vous avez quand vous
êtes client de ce qui serait scandaleux
c'est que le nouveau de téléphone où
l'on soit obligé de l'acheter parce que
les anciens ne fonctionne plus avec moi
j'ai un tour à six il fonctionne très
bien j'ai pas besoin du douzy'k cdrs
donc il ya des chaussures il ya aussi
des choses sur 1 200 euros des jeux soit
1600 euros à la personne nous l'un des
jeunes avait déjà obligé de faire un
choix qui va y en avoir être tombé du
camion
[Musique]
merci